tips as temp temperatures continue to
rise and the energy the sponsors of this
next segment are here for you rocky
spoke with them to learn more about
their program that helps families
maintain stable bills and cool homes
air conditioning accounts for
approximately 50 of your summer energy
bill and adam grant of nb energy has
some tips for you southern nevada as we
brave these triple digit temperatures
one of the great things that we
recommend is before the summer heat
which is started already here in las
vegas to get your air conditioner looked
at we have a program for qualified
customers to get their air conditioner
tuned up and we have a program that also
replaces less efficient units with a
more efficient air conditioning unit and
getting that done at the beginning of
summer before there's the heat is
probably a great thing for customers to
do that program is power shift by envy
energy offering two services to help
customers keep their ac efficient when
it matters the most one of the options
we have is for air conditioning units
where we can come over for qualified
customers and do a tune-up of your unit
to check out to see if it's working as
efficiently as possible so how does the
replacement and installation process
work let's talk to a technician i'm
jeremy anderson owner of express home
services
like adam said when you have the
services done for your ac maintenance
what you can expect from us is for a
certified
technician to come out take a look at
the air conditioner go through all the
maintenance steps with them take a look
at the contactors the capacitors
condenser fan motors check the
refrigerant charge take the cleanliness
of the system do a light cleaning on the
system to make sure that it's achieving
top performance and that it's ready for
summer the process takes typically an
hour to an hour and a half to do a
proper tune-up we're utilizing the
latest and greatest technology
when it comes to checking the air
conditioner to make sure that we're
doing a great job so all that you really
need to do is contact a licensed
contractor to come out that's part of
the power shift program and they can get
you taken care of the power shift team
wants to empower you making sure your
bills stay stable and your home stays
cool one of the recommendations we make
is to set your thermostat this time of
year at 78 degrees we have a program
that will give you a free smart
thermostat as part of our power shift
bundle which gives you this thermostat
what the option is for you to set
schedule set it for 78 when you're home
maybe 85 when you're not at home and you
can do that automatically with
technology that we offer for free and
here's an important reminder this
program is open to all nv energy
customers replacing a unit is easy as
calling a contractor getting them to
come take a look at what you need and we
offer incentives from 200 all the way up
to 1800 based on the size of the unit
you replace
so we recommend customers do it before
the unit breaks down to ensure that
you're living in a warm home while
someone can come out and take care of
you and the incentive becomes higher
whatever unit you get if it's done
before the burnout
powershift by nb energy air conditioning
incentives are at nvenergy.com
ac